there were plenty of shakes happening on
stage at the Tony Awards
the show did go on in the midst of the
rider strike and host Ariana Dubose did
the thing off the cuff a live and
unscripted you're welcome
[Applause]
leading up to the broadcast presenter
uzo aduba announced she's expecting her
first child with husband Robert Sweeney
by cradling her growing belly
Broadway Alum Lupita Nyong'o described
this daring fashion statement as a quote
Shameless Out of Body Experience the
silver breastplate was cast and molded
from her actual body
funny girl star Leah Michelle went way
more traditional in this red and white
floral gown Leah was not eligible for a
nomination since she did not open the
musical as its star but the former Glee
star still took the stage and performed
don't ring around a cloud
and the Tony for most random guest went
to Aaron Rodgers he hit the carpet with
his Jets teammate CJ uzama this shot of
Rogers in the Audi quickly went viral
with one person tweeting quote Aaron
Rodgers looks like he just spotted a
member of his family another viral
moment
[Music]
nominee Samuel L Jackson's losing face
complete with an eye roll after getting
passed over in his category I am Samuel
Ellison honored to be nominated Jackson
Jessica Chastain a first-time nominee
for her role in a doll's house looked
like a Broadway superhero in this bright
yellow caped gown she hit the carpet
with her mom Jessica can you guys turn
this way Jessica lost the best
performance by an actress in a leading
role to Prima facie's star Jody Comer
Sean Hayes
sure yes like that the Will and Grace
star took home his first Tony for his
leading role in the play good night
Oscar he plays real life pianist Oscar
Levant and that's really Sean playing on
stage yeah I'm still icing seven days a
week and um it's exhausting but very
rewarding the night also made history
Some Like It Hots Jay Harrison gee and
shuksar Alex Newell became the first
non-binary people to win Tonys for
acting hi friends of my dad and Jennifer
Gray teared up while presenting her dad
famed Broadway star Joel gray with the
Lifetime Achievement Award my daughter
my sweetness seven pounds 11 ounces